des Premières Nations du Québec
et du Labrador, Ghislain Picard,
Chef Picard, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Chef Picard, vous avez
entendu les paroles du pape.
Est-ce que ça répo
à vos attentes? Est-ce que
ça répond aux attentes
des peuples autochtones?
GHISLAIN PICARD, chef, Ass.
Premières Nations Qc et Labrador
- Bien je vais commencer par
la fin. Bon, vous avez parlé
de pardon. Est-ce que ça va
nous permettre d'aller vers
le pardon? C'est vraiment,
selon nous, quelque chose
qui appartient aux survivants.
C'est à eux que les paroles ont
été, pour eux, que les paroles
ont été prononcées et donc
ultimement, c'est vraiment à eux
et à elles qu'il appartient
d'assurer la suite, incluant
le pardon. Si... si, ça se rend
jusque-là. Ce que je peux dire,
c'est que... il y a très
certainecertainecertainecertainn
que le pape ait fait l'effort
au Canada, donc
de répondre à la demande que
la délégation avait transmise
en avrilen avrilen avrilen avris
pour qu'il puisse se déplacer
au Canada et faire...présenter ,
les réitérer finalement,
ici-même, sur les territoires
ancestraux des peuples
autochtones.
Donc, il y a, si je peux
me permettre, une partie de
la marchandise qui est livrée
à ce moment-ci. Mais ultimement,
que ça soit l'acceptation
des excuses, c'est vraiment
aux survivants que cette
étape-là appartient.
- Il y a nécessairement
des expériences individuelles,
alors ce processus-là d'accepter
ses, il est aussi
individuel. Mais vous,
quand vous l'avez entendu,
le pape, est-ce que vous aviez
l'impression qu'il pesait
sur les bons boutons ou
il disait les bons mots
pour que potentiellement,
les Autochtones puissent
accepter ces excuses-là?
- Bien, ce qu'il f,
c'est que l'Église catholique
est quand même la dernière
Église à se rendre aussi loin,
hein. Trente ans après l'Église
anglicane, qui la précède
finalement. Et pour moi,
c'est important d'être conscient
que ça fait longtemps
que les survivants attendent,
et on en a perdu plusieurs
en cours de route aussi.
Ça, il ne faut pas l'oublier
non plus. Mais ceci étant dit,
le processus est quand même
extrêmement, je dirais,
laborieux, parce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait reconnaissance
que des torts ont été causés,
et, en partie, je pense
que le message livré par
le pape François porte
cette reconnaissance-là;
que des torts ont été causés.
Et ensuite, il y a l'expression
des excuses par le pape
lui-même. Et je pense que
tout ça est reçu aujourd'hui
avec la présence de survivants
et qui ont sans doute
des émotions très, très diverses
paroles.
Et on le voit aujourd'hui, des s
qui disent : "Bon, c'est pas
assez." D'autres qui disent :
"Bon, moi, ça m'apporte
le réconfort nécessaire."
Donc, il y aura une diversité
d'opinions et d'émotions
à travers des milliers de
survivants qui sont encore
parmi nous aujourd'hui.
Donc, et par la suite, il y a,
comme vous dites vous-même,
le processus de guérison,
qui est, oui, collectif,
commel'a bien précisé
la Commission vérité et
réconciliation, mais
qui est conditionné également
pour une guérison,
une guérison individuelle.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose
qu'il ne faut absolument pas
négliger également.
Et par la suite,
bien, ultimement, on parle
du pardon, évidemment.
Et encore une fois, un geste
qui appartient aux individus,
aux survivants, entièrement,
et viendra ensuite réparation.
Et je pense que c'est
un processus qui va demander
du temps.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas
à en douter, mais il faudra
être patient. Il faudra surtout
être patient avec les attentes
exprimées, qu'exprimeront
les survivants.
- Vous l'avez dit,
une délégation au Vatican avait
demandé au pape de venir faire
ses excuses ici, au Canada.
Pourquoi elles étaient
nécessaires, ces excuses-là?
Elles changent quoi pour
les personnes qui ont été
victimes de ces pensionnats
autochtones?
- Eh bien, tout le monde
souhaite guérir, hein.
Je parle des survivants
et je suis conscient que
tout le monde veuille également
tourner la page.
Mais c'est quand même tourner
la page sur des épisodes
qui sont très tristes, hein,
où on a complètement écorché
la dignité humaine,
et un vécu qui a longtemps
été caché. On ajoute à ça tous
les sentiments de culpabilité,
de honte et de haine.
Et je crois souvent que dans
cette espèce de retenue
de l'Église catholique pendant
les 40 dernières années,
les 30 dernières années,
on a carrément sous-estimé
ces sentiments-là,
qui habitent encore aujourd'hui
les survivants.
Donc, pour moi, c'est...
et je crois que, en tout cas,
lorsque j'entends les paroles
du pape François, je sens
qu'il y a cette sincérité-là.
Mais cela étant dit,
encore une fois,
au risque de me répéter,
c'est vraiment une mesure
que seuls les survivants
sont en mesure de prendre.
- Vous êtes le chef
de l'Assemblée des Premières
Nations du Québec et du
Labrador, Ghislain Picard,
je vous